aterrizamos en ciudad de panamá y
nuestro corresponsal de oscar sulbarán a
oscar los saludo muy buena mañana de
martes el presidente de ese país latino
cortizo hizo algunas concesiones al
movimiento de protesta pero aún así no
logró desactivarlo entonces le pregunto
oscar que se esperaba para el día de hoy
hola raúl si el día de ayer el
presidente de la república a laurentino
cortizo se dirigía a los panameños luego
de haber estado sentí una semana del
país y justamente cuando el presidente
estuvo ausente iniciaron estás
[Aplausos]
derivaron en el apoyo de varios gremios
y sindicatos a favor de las demandas que
comenzaron primeramente por el gremio
docente luego se le fueron uniendo
grupos las protestas se mantienen en
diversos
puntos de el país en distintos puntos
del país a pesar como tú bien dices del
anuncio que hizo el presidente de
laurentino cortizo la tarde de ayer y
que tiene que ver con que el
congelamiento de precios de la gasolina
y además incluir una serie de artículos
de la canasta básica en un control de
precios sin embargo las protestas
permanecen algunos grupos ya habían
anunciado que para el día 2 y estaba
prevista una gran marcha que tendría
como destino el palacio presidencial de
las garzas ahí se mantienen y se ha
mantenido las protestas en diversas
zonas del país que siendo panamá un país
pequeño y prácticamente una sola
arteria que comunica a toda la nación se
ha visto gráfica que más bien los
manifestantes es oscar
dentro de las razones e incluso ahora
las manifestaciones que se han dado en
las últimas horas luego del anuncio
presidencial estos manifestantes han
dicho que no es sólo el tema de la
gasolina
e incluir un grupo de
productos de la canasta alimentaria en
un control de precios y nuestro también
tiene que ver con algo que se ha
reclamado
y ya tiene tiempo y es la contención de
gastos de la que ha hablado el gobierno
que no se ha hecho realidad que sigue
aumentando los gastos incluso el
ministro
[Música]
indicaba que el gobierno panameño
seguían pagando
lo que tiene que ver con la planilla
estatal con parte de la deuda